读书是可以赚钱的,你们知道吧,这个事其实特别简单
就这条视频
很短的时间就告诉你
读书怎么赚钱
怎么能够快速协息,你顺便还能把那个短视频做的,然后找到自己的商业模式
马上就告诉你
首先第一步
真的是找一个不是好书
真的是找好书,找这个领导好书,比如说你要是真的想重视哪个领域
这次跟成长第一位的
比如说我我的事也没有开过,作为不同人,我一直看不到这个事情
我觉得那边这个书就不错
对吧,我想更深一点,可能看出他的一包店
可能我想做的小声音,那就看小儿美,对吧,可能说我一开始
我文化随便也不高
然后我想有一个入门的,那你可以看
读书解这些法,对吧
就是找这个领域的好书什么是好书
一个不要准吧
就一本书在一本在本,在本
对吧,然后平时将来说也不要高,这种书差不多
至少不会太差,好了,这是第一个
第二件事情
找到这个领域的书的之后的话,真的花点时代认证看书啊,兄弟们
真的花点时代认证看书,书中自由,研瘤,书中自由,方英误
研瘤这个事
我不好证明,但是黄英误这个事我可能证明,那就两分钟
然后呢
读书怎么读书,我教你个方法
首先呢,就是你要看读书
读书呢,就是这个人说我这本书讲什么
然后里面那些张棋
里面那些张棋
然后大小标题呀,中间啊,对,看书的时候不要着急,就是人人看进去
读书是这个世界上最占便宜的,是我一直
我写书在这本书里边要起来特别清楚
读书就是占便宜
有人家总结的几十年的经验
对吧,让你很快用学会的,你可以和几百年前的人在一块狗中,你可以和当今最牛的人一的狗中
你和他的思想狗中,你不要写书后,书中正在是好东西,认人看
好了,中年来了
一般来说,这个作课为了告诉你什么是中间
他通常会在这个书上给你做一些特殊的符号,对吧,比如说
颜色或者加粗,你比如说我这位书
就会加粗,你看他没
这个位置就会加粗,我认为这个地方你要重点看啊
然后我就会给他加粗
加粗的部分
或重点用书中点,就是做的重点标的部分是作者认为
你应该学到了,说明这个知识中校的
大家看的时候
结合上下来看啊,看看哦,我这个书讲什么
然后的话,他是怎么讲的,他的主要观点是什么
好了,有了这个,表示作者观众是什么,对不对,好,还有一个
我建议大家
除了指数之外的话,最好可能还会有一些电子书
然后你看完了以后,你再看电子书
看电子书的时候,通常来说,如果又是用书加粗的地方
在上半,可能就会有虚现,看见面
说明很多人在滑线了
滑线了以后的话,这就是很多人看这个
这个断落的时候,他们是怎么理解的,他们是怎么理解的
他们有什么的想法,他们的观点是什么
各位
这种大量的评论,有些长温的评论
说明什么
说明很多人对这段那种是有干误的,是有自己的感受的,是有供民的
别人画现的评论
表示大家对这本书的理解
如果越多,评论的越多,观点越多,什么大家越喜欢这个东西
天洞了吧
如果做了加黑,表示做着人们这个东西很重要,好了
那么这个部分,你会发现又是有用的支持同时人们有喜欢,那么这个会只要重点看
然后加上你的观点,你要
你把你的观点抗了以后,好好的思好好的理解
完了以后,把它交给AI的进对话,然后进入主题的读
这个时候,你多多少少会有一些自己的想法了
然后画上途
你的理解,你在生活中的理解,这段那种,好了,是不是你有感受了
有感受了以后,拿起视频
排一条视频吧
对吧,就是
真真实实,没有做任何选传,就是
我今天读到这本书里边有这么一个观点,然后我的观点的是什么
其实你是有深度研究的
这就是一条视频,是不是内容就有了
如果你每天读书每天,读内容
不是吗
碎里边
把这个书
挂到你的厨手里就像我现在一样,这本书是挂到厨手里,那你不做选传,你只是告诉别人,这本书我真的读过了,而且我真的觉得很好
我把他分享给你,别人有感觉,哦,原来这个书是这样的,他获取对我有帮助,没帮助你算了,有帮助人家就会购买
是不是就会有人购买你的书
各位,你重要的吗
本身就是费满学义吧,不知
当你发出去以后下面会有很联系论
相当于一个读书校
说我今天读里边说我是这么这么厉害,相当好准这样,我是这么厉害,我这么厉害,我这么厉害,你还会有帮助你学习,一看还有这么多人帮助你学习
所以各位,你看
这个读书已经记得了,你记得了书,你学到只是个人又成长了,然后你还做到短视频,然后你还赚了钱,同时你还打造了一块产品
所以以后我吹牛的时候,不要跟人说,我要去年读得多本书,你应该说,去年有多少人
然后我先提醒我
读了多少本书